so we know that being on set is not just
acting it's navigating personalities and
politics and hierarchies how do you earn
the respect of a fellow actor do the
work do the work do the work
and it's funny because you go into
certain projects you know with an Ed
Harris like Westworld and on this film
as well but I already won Ed's respect
in this film and in Westford I had not
so you know I called a few friends that
had worked with him to find out a little
background on them and then um I just
studied really hard I studied really
hard to learn my lines I studied hard to
learn his lines just in case he was like
what's my line why I'd be able to like I
think I think you say but uh maybe this
is I don't know you never know how was
gonna take it like he had to navigate so
I'm navigating and um and he goes oh
thanks partner
all right so I did that and then I
slammed the scene where my daughter my
wife gets killed and then he came
running over to me and just pointing at
me and filth in and for all things like
yes yes yes and he kicks me in
my shin like real hard and he goes
that's how you do it and anybody walked
away I was like I hope that's gonna
leave a mark but it Harris did that
makes it get a good job it's pretty rad
it's pretty awesome so that's how I got
his respect but I'm sure there's
different yeah it's like you said you
got to navigate a navigation jacket and
I was dying to get his respect
um probably you know I mean he's
definitely a great mentor you know only
second of my grandfather you know um but
this man knows everybody's lines you
knows everybody's lives he knows what
the camera moved on what line and where
he did what and he knows everything
it's really amazing so I am Henry her
CIL's mmm rehearsal Samuel I know he was
teaching me less we've had this
conversation before so
he's got these giant monologues at the
end of the film that are actually much
better than wouldn't even ended up in
the film and in rehearsals he Kevin
Reynolds like ain't he ready you guys
ready to do this scene yeah man let's do
it
and sim looks up he's like yeah man he
throws his scenes on the floor he's got
the big speeches anyway so I might hold
my gun and then he just like looks up
him you got tears he can control this
sign this I too by the way
he can make this cry right now you can
make this cry he can hold them I can't
do that but he can so when I saw him
holding the tears and he literally just
put the pedal to the metal and I thought
oh my god I I don't know if I can ever
be that good sigh I just remember uh
just racing home racing home and just
delving as deeply as I could just to get
any ounce of respect from him yeah he's
a tough love kind of guy so you got
really really really earned it yeah
sometimes those people are easier to
trust you know especially in an industry
where you know every you know you want
to be professional but sometimes tough
love people are actually easier to to
trust cuz you kind of know where they're
coming from mmm yeah I mean I talked to
him quite often nice yeah I honestly
didn't really know I think this came I
lost my father to a suicide two days I
was at my father's funeral two days
before the climax of the movie and we
shot the movie in sequence so I was
really emotional
rather suicidal type of scenario and we
done the rehearsal and they had already
asked me if they minded if I would mind
doing my coverage first instead of
Samuel it's first because I was
obviously dealing with some heavy life
issues they all supported me
tremendously and it was I think it was
then that I actually had the courage to
even ask what's what same thing about
the work I'm doing anyway
like sure we can do coverage on me I'm
when what is that it's Samko it says it
was San Juans because I'll do it her San
Juans and they were like yeah he's
totally fine with it and that's when I
asked them because Samuel himself didn't
tell me he was holding it close to the
chest it was really dope good I mean
hello them so it's interesting because
when sometimes you're at a point where
it's like certain things are going on
and if everything falls apart it's okay
you know we were having this
conversation driving over here as long
as you you know and I'm stealing your
words by the way sorry you were saying
something about staying true to yourself
so I think sometimes in those moments
some amazing things can happen because
you're at this point where you're not
really about pleasing somebody you're
just kind of like doing what's right in
the moment and sometimes really amazing
things can happen it started way to live
I've been learning you know I think
making as true as we think we're being
to ourselves we can always be a little
truer you know seeking a depth of
authenticity if you will you don't like
like I just I've just on this crazy
journey lately through my work and the
demands of trying to do better work this
pushed me to to lose sleep and study
harder and faster and just go longer and
it's um it's just interesting because if
you pay attention to the signs in those
moments and do what's right you know
what speaks to your integrity
I can always rest well with whatever
happens you know I'm not feeling bad I'm
feeling good about the decisions I make
that's a good feeling
thank you for watching our interview
with clifton collins jr. for those of
you who enjoy this content and live in
los angeles we invite you to experience
film courage live we have two upcoming
events this tuesday october 16th we have
a filmmaking panel with filmmakers
Christopher Rea Andrew P Jones Royce
Gorsuch Orson Ovitz and Brian Aven and
Bradley and on Tuesday October 23rd we
have a one-night-only class with Pamela
J Smith entitled mythic challenges
creates stories that change the world we
are excited to host both events we have
links in the description below if you
would like to attend